[Music]
I'd like to make three introductory
remarks first of all that certainly a
pleasure and honor to talk about L&S on
this occasion secondly I'd like to thank
League Watsons Jean Flanagan and the
staff of our headquarters office and
Bates for all the effort that has gone
into this and third I haven't timed this
talk finishing at about 10:00 or 11:00
o'clock last night so Peter I think the
limits are probably to be somewhat
greater than 4.6 minutes somewhat less
than 46 years and we'll have to move
ahead at the rate of about a year a
minute so let me let me begin i remind
our visitors that the work of the
laboratory is fundamental studies the
atomic nucleus its makeup and the forces
among its various constituents
the laboratory was announced December
19th by Karl Compton named Jerrold
Zacharias as its first director and
really got underway in 1946 there we
have Gerald
Mac Hubbard the fellow that's missing is
Ralph crowd and I was a young Navy
lieutenant and over in building 20
working with a winner at the time and
when Zach Mac and Ralph came over to see
you you knew you had real problems in
your hands
Zach's formula for success in this most
simplistic way is get the best give them
the best give them their head and the
best will result if we take a look at
the laboratory it was a
interdepartmental laboratory programs
and physics and chemistry its objectives
education training research all pulled
together with a strong support of
central facilities both administration
and technical in fact from one his acts
early talks he was interested in trying
to get nuclear and particle there is to
talk to each other which he did the
nuclear and experimental to talk to each
other and then these groups also talking
all embedded in a framework tied
together with technical and
administrative services the laboratory
had an initial structure very similar to
what we now see for the steering
committee Advisory Committee a
Directorate programs in physics
chemistry engineering and again tied
together with its strong administrative
and technical facilities its initial
scientific program covered theory cosmic
rays physics and chemistry engineering a
modest budget of a million dollars a
year or so and me2 me3 vandegraaff a
seven MeV stacked with Geron but with
more to come here we have a listing of
the so-called Planck participants and
maybe term to indicate those that were
here initially it reads like a who's who
of MIT at the time those were the the P
after their names represent those that
have
taking major responsibilities in the
laboratory the ones with an asterisk or
those that are still with us I think
Martin and talking a bit said that I
think he is the longest member of this
group at MIT being here some 56 years of
course the laboratories such as this
needs support this was the first
proposal submitted to ONR and you see
the seed was a very modest proposal at
that time a morning to some three
million dollars for equipment and about
a million each for nuclear science and
nuclear engineering support
we even had hopes of a building at that
time this is now the site I think of
building 16 which never quite came to
pass we take a look at the campus in the
early years
I won't caught up the number
accelerators but if we had the time we'd
find eight there were five vandegraaff
so when cyclotron one synchrotron and
one linic and here is mass Avenue Vassar
Street we were concentrating in this
part of the campus with our headquarters
initially in building 20 in fact our
shops are still here and occasionally we
would have a bit of fun at Christmas and
get together wearily and L&S was in
building 20 and at the Cambridge
boathouse and for those with good eyes
you might spot a young Vickie vice cop
and Bernie Feld
on this occasion let me jump ahead a bit
and the own our contract lasted about 12
years and at that time cruise owed from
80 a little conducted a study and let's
see if some of Zacharias is initial
objectives were met
okay Zach was into everything I mean we
undertook projects Charles Hartwell and
lamplight was a national defense
many people were trained 78 PhDs a
thousand senior theses new knowledge new
companies and I go back here to
certainly some of the early publications
in fact I went to my library it's in the
basement at home and found copies of
Latin vice cop at one point said them
was stolen book in the MIT library
forest of mesh Bachman and studies of
the atomic nucleus by roble heaven and
many others now what I'd like to do in
terms of describing their work in the
laboratory I do it in terms of a tree
and the initial tree we have here is
sort of black and white rather stark
through the help of actually what key
the EMI Group secretary and their
McIntosh we were able to put together a
tree such as you see right here now for
a tree to thrive it has to have strong
roots you have to be able to prune it
and let me just call attention to some
of the roots and I'll just try to
categorize these here the leadership
it's certainly been superb it's been my
great pleasure to work with all of these
physicist men through the years and
certainly I found in so doing each one
of them a very warm human being if we
take a look at the physics faculty
students and LNS staff at categorize
this by excellence and highly motivated
our central facilities by dedication MIT
very strong support you look at this 14
million dollars that's 14 million
dollars in an account and that gave us
certainly a another dimension in terms
of solving logistic problems this goes
back to the days of George Harrison Dean
Albert II vice presidents Tom Jones L
Hill Dean Brown and
Bob Birgeneau then this route right here
was certainly very very strong primarily
one contract some 450 million dollars
the government money has come into the
laboratory starting with O&R and then
moving off to the AEC her de do e and
with help along the way from OSR and NIH
and here again we were I think very
fortunate and being able to work with
men that were real professionals
physicists going back to the days of
Paul McDaniel Jim Lise bill Hess bill
Walden Mayer John O'Fallon building
Ernie Hildebrand on the hydrogen side of
the house and on the nuclear side of the
house George kallstadt Clarence
Richardson Dave Hendry and others at
times they would give us a very they
come here usually once a year for a
review of our work would give us a hard
time but at the same time and work with
us in solving problems so we have a very
very strong root structure now in terms
of looking at these branches where
should I begin let me start with cosmic
ray physics I categorize this for those
of you that like the out-of-doors it's
fun physics and if we take a look at
this particular branch Bruno came to MIT
in 1946 and you'll hear some of the
details from George Clark but he brought
with him the Four Horseman bridge
Thompson Williams met sands and starting
in the mushroom caves they might think
of the cosmic group hoop is just moving
out towards outer space
they had experiments at the cosmic Tron
giant air shower experiments in various
parts of the world balloon flights b-29
flights satellite flights and then about
1961 they moved to the aegis of the form
the nucleus of the Center for Space
Research let us take a look at some of
the things along the way
nuclear emotions were used very early on
in fact Bernie Feld went to England and
came back with techniques at the
laboratory used wasn't b-29 flights and
here on the surface of the earth here we
have a cosmic ray particle interacting
and forming a star and of course some of
the questions you're asking yourself
or what what are they cosmic rays what
does their makeup how do they interact
where do they come from and these were
some of the questions that this group
was attempting to answer here we have
one of the early devices a high-pressure
cloud chamber where we have a rare event
the death of a cosmic Ramazan coming
down through this plate dying here
forming an electron and the neutron goes
off here
these were devices were taken to higher
altitudes to the cosmic ray station in
Echo Lake many interesting stories here
about our central facilities people
going out and installing things coming
down the mountain with Bill Smith a
hair-raising adventure but all of them
safely reached the bottom then we have
Bruno developing the multi-plate cloud
chamber and here we have a cosmic ray
particle interacting in the plates of
this chamber forming a shower of
particles about 1953 the group moved to
the studies of air showers and giant air
showers here you'd like to learn
something about the energy of the
primary ray you'd like to learn
something about its direction of arrival
so as it comes down through the
atmosphere you have a wave of particles
and in order to detect what happens you
have to set up your detectors over a
rather wide area and you have to have
fast electronics if indeed you're going
to catch this wave as it as it passes by
so where could we install such an
experiment remember George Clark and I
travel up and down the eastern seaboard
trying to find a place we went to
Squanto
we went to other places and finally
settled at the Harvard Observatory start
at Harvard Mass or initially something
like I believe 15 detectors were
installed out there the diameter here of
about 3/10 of a mile and with a detector
consisting of a flammable fluid benzene
with tur phenol added for scintillating
properties many interesting things
evolved around this experiment one of
the first of course you have cables
coming back and the mice and the
squirrels would certainly attacked the
cables and then shortly after the array
was put in operation I think about three
or four days there was an intense
electrical storm one of these caught
fire
I remember writing back in the car with
the vice president Reynolds from Harvard
Bruno Bruno has head in his hands
because at that time they detected one
of the highest energy cosmic rays ever
seen about 10 to the 18 electron volts
Rendell's was saying Bruno you gotta get
that off my property I don't want you to
burn down the observatory then we had
coal man sage that sages father who was
the crusty old colonel heading up the D
IC Division of industrial cooperation at
that time talked to Reynolds we got a
repeat and then we had to try to
fireproof this array as best we could
and here the laboratory really joined
forces we went out with shovels barrels
full of sand Peter and I had the job of
developing a snuffer a tub snuffer so
that if one of these caught on fire the
tub would drop many interesting fires
across the parking lot in building 20
where the MIT Safety Office watching
sympathetically the array was put back
into operation and it went on for about
I'd say three or four months and during
that during that period we developed
inflammable or feather material
polystyrene discs the largest ever
developed to replace the flammable
benzene and indeed bill Smith was the
one responsible for these these were
built in a the gas turbine lab again
across Vassar Street somebody from MIT
told me gee if that burns down you'd be
doing us a favor I remember many
warnings walking up the street
and getting this strong whiff of
polystyrene as these things are being
cooked then these moved out to the
volcano at site site in Bock at near
Albuquerque New Mexico but John Linsley
Livio scar see Peter and I would visit
this site these were a much larger array
to try to really probe further out and
detect primaries of higher energy and
walking with John he would lick one of
these covers and there might be a
rattlesnake there nonchalantly pick it
up throw it out and of course Peter and
I would quickly move to be sure it
didn't land on us but in the middle
1950s or late 1950s John detected
probably but at that time was
energy cosmic array of its kind about 10
to the 20th evey which because of its
energy indicated it must be coming from
outside our galaxy
these are moved into Bolivia the badge
day experiment of not chacaltaya at
18,000 feet and along the way some of
our graduate students at interesting
times doing revolutions spending their
time in the cellars of the paws and then
on to balloon flights you want to probe
up get up higher into the atmosphere so
this was done here we have such an array
going up the flight might last about
five hours the package might move about
25 miles but you'd like to get up higher
more complicated instrument
instrumentation was developed bigger
balloons and these would go up to
altitudes and possibly as high as 130
thousand feet with about 10 million
cubic feet of gas and I think some of
the early reports of flying saucers were
the Sun reflecting off flight such as
this then into outer space the here is a
Faraday cup the plasma probe a bridge
and Rossi here we have them taking a
look at it here in the laboratory in
building 26
this was flown on Explorer 10 I think in
the early 1960s and gave us information
about the solar wind and the geomagnetic
environment close to the earth then
you'd like to probe the matter density
of the Galactic halo as you can do and
means of gamma rays Croucher Clarke and
Cher develop this package which was then
flown on another satellite and then in
conclusion I'd like to say one of the
things that this group did was really
involved physicist erm all over the
world a strong component from India from
Italy from China and Japan
so that briefly is the work on cosmic
ray physics
let us go back to the tree and let us
see what branch should we look at next
before doing so I should I should point
out that in the early years there were
very strong programs of nuclear
chemistry in the laboratory fission
element organic chemistry and organic
chemistry chion-in Swain Crale and
Irvine Roberts George scatcherd and also
there was this little branch right here
starting off for the design of a nuclear
reactor in the laboratory because of its
size and complexity
this work was moved into the Department
of nuclear engineering about 1951 the
reactor with first reactor was completed
about 1958 ourselves a five megawatt
water-cooled reactor it was upgraded in
the 70s it's still continues today doing
forefront basic research in the life
sciences and physical sciences looking
at the lower energy branch we see rats
here look at the proliferation of
accelerators we have a 2 MeV vandegraaff
4 MeV the onr generator because Owen our
sponsor did the Marcos cyclotron the
radioactivity center under Roble Evans
much interesting work full-body
dosimetry radioisotopes the study of
long-term effects of radium poisoning
and individuals the radioactivity branch
here under Graz ins and Martin Deutsch
many things happened here to discover
you positronium mas para tech work
nuclear energy energy levels decay
schemes and what have you and then when
all of this was finished this coalesced
into a heavy ion group Steve Steadman
Bob LeDoux Eric Osmond Harold Enger
moving off to work at Oak Ridge Denton
Brookhaven initially at the tandem AG s
and hopefully with Rick let's take a few
minutes to look at some of this work
here is where the vandegraaff work
started at a tabletop and Princeton this
is the world's first vandegraaff this
was constructed at the Round Hill site
Round Hill mass about a two mvv machine
was brought to MIT and some interesting
work earlier work in the elastic
inelastic scattering of electrons and
Herman Feshbach fitted
Rowland unraveling some of the theories
on that then we say in terms of
accelerators the AEC has a book that
tells you how long a an accelerator
should exist 15 to 20 years either
recycled or they're scrapped in this
case the machine was recycled to the
Museum of Science in Boston then we have
the four MeV rocket
Rockefeller generator it did some early
interesting work and what we call the
wolf-whistle effect where the electric
field of the proton without smashing
into the nucleus with one was able to
produce excited States and study nuclear
structures through that method and then
we had plans for a 12 MeV vandegraaff
this was installed in the early 1950s
and building 58 and schematically what
we see right here is the machine beam of
particles protons coming down
interacting with a target being
magnetically analyzed and depending upon
their energies focused onto this focal
plane and then living their presence in
terms of little tracks in the nuclear
emulsion and here we had large scanning
groups consulates tracks as a distance
along the plate giving these Peaks
and much of this work was energy level
work it was probably one of the world's
most foremost facilities at the time and
all aimed at a better understanding of
the nucleus buckner to see right here
and any spent many many days and weeks
developing new instrumentation and here
you have one of the spectrographs they
developed the multiple spectrograph and
then in parallel there was a lot of work
going on at MIT in the laboratory at
that time by John Trump John developed
several vandegraaff this one was used to
study the properties of materials the
properties of gases to improve the
vandegraaff as a research tool also he
developed an electron vandegraaff for
studies and the irradiation of deep 200
here we have the michael cyclotron this
came into being in the early 1940s and
initially it's a seven MeV proton
machine used for the production of Radio
isotopes and then for nuclear studies
and with sandy Wald and Aaron Bernstein
developed a lot of very fine
instrumentation to be able to use the
proton deuteron and the alpha particle
beams from that machine here the
cyclotron laid dormant for a number of
years that really was just a pilot junk
but then this was resurrected by one of
our high energy groups under Ulrich
Becker
he wanted to use the magnetic field for
gas studies for muon detectors for
high-energy work we even had plans for a
tandem but that was scrapped in favor of
the linic and then of course the very
interesting series a series of
experiments by Martin Deutsch and
positronium where you have a positron
electron come together briefly to form
an atom of positronium and this was
certainly one of the as I see it one of
the very important achievements and then
studying the properties of positronium
and then with all of these accelerators
dying we call s the own our generator
group radioactivity grew up into a heavy
ion group and now just look at the
complexity of what you see right here
this is experiment 802 at Brookhaven
spearheaded by Steve Steadman to study
heavy ion beams of oxygen silicon
interacting with gold targets and also
as far as the future is concerned under
the goose' we and Steve and Bernie
wodsworth we hope to do experiments at
the Rick heavy ion accelerator at
Brookhaven in the late 1990s in fact a
proposal will shortly be submitted for
the four bus detector by Veet
where we hope to study new forms of
matter the clerk to run plasma so that
is the work in nuclear physics if we
come to medium energy physics I can
categorize this by excellence on a
shoestring
let us go back to our tree we take a
look right here at this branch and this
to me is a one of the amazing branches
of the tree starting in building 20 when
that work was finished moving to RPI nvs
Saskatchewan and then about the
mid-1960s the the bringing online in
early 1970 of a 400 MeV linic and here
one could tell all sorts of stories I
remember in the office when pewter was
talking with Paul McDaniel and saying
look it I've got to have seven million
bucks for this accelerator and Paul said
look at that's my entire budget I'll
give you a half and I think that's been
the name of the game sort of living with
half all along but coming forward with a
very very remarkable forefront facility
the first linic was finished about 1972
and then along the way was added a
second area that was equipped every
circulator and now this also ring which
will give it's 1 GeV a CW capability
should be finished in about a year or so
I think of a satchel page that said that
look at that if you're running a race
don't look don't look back somebody's
level to be catching up I think that's
what we see right here that dates has
always been running and due to the
supreme and I would say tremendous
leadership of Peter demos Ernie Moniz in
Austin Kowalski they are running never
looking back and in the process that
they brought up one of the world's most
foremost facilities here is where it all
started in building 20 this is a 7 10 M
evil in act 21 magnetrons a world war 2
a radar tube phase so that this beam of
2 MeV electrons is accelerated down to
an energy of 17 mb v and much
interesting work and photo fishin photo
production of neutrons time-of-flight
studies with peter demos but in fact had
to take a year off from graduate studies
to bring this machine into being bill
sergeant bill Berto Z Bob Deb's and many
others young Halperin involved in the
early work
here we have the dates as it is today
and I just mentioned a few things the
initial machine was right here the
recirculate er is here the initial
machine included in North Hall when then
added the capability of a polarized
source the South Hall came into being
equipped and now we have the South Hall
ring right in this area right here
you'll hear more about distant bill
Church and it's and others here's a
picture of dates as seen from the air
and here we're looking down the linic
and again some interesting stories when
this tunnel was first developed it was
about 600 600 feet long here's the
injector right here I remember walking
down it with Peter built church and
that's I think George kallstadt and a
few others j-jake hampson POIs Reardon
was probably there also with us six to
eight inches of water mud sludge because
up on the hill there was a reservoir of
some five million gallons of water that
continually seeped down Jake was shaking
his head and saying my god how can we
ever build a machine in here how can I
bring my linen my waveguides into this
area and George also was interested in
neutron time-of-flight and say gee
where's my neutron time-of-flight hole
so we got some of their workers to bore
a nice hole and every time George came
by said George here and time-of-flight
of all and then here is the North Hall
the Elsi spectrometer a number of
interesting stories about this at times
the physicist I think has to follow his
gut feeling and in terms of what he
wants to do and I think gilberto Z here
did just this one of the elements were
the four pieces he wanted to use a form
of a nickel steel which had only been
produced in small pieces he thought that
by doing this this would give him a a
certainly a high resolution capability
many people said bill don't do it
he went ahead and did it and I think now
we have one again one of the world's
finest instruments here in the north
wall extremely high high resolution
and in the South Hall we take a look
here are some of the the MEP
spectrometers OHIP spectrometers that
you'll hear more about and again magnets
are recycled here we have the Princeton
pen magnets these are being used for the
in the Southall ring and then what is it
all about this came from a little note I
found in some stuff I got from Bill lobe
are what goes on two dates it has some
80 to 90 people experiments are approved
by a program Advisory Committee and a
typical experiment takes two to three
hundred hours and a breadth of physics
is just to me mind-boggling nuclear
structure work cause the elastic
scattering photo production coincidence
experiments polarization experiments
just a breath of superb physics and then
they'll enact and its staff continue to
run they're not looking back here we
have an utter plain spectrometer that is
now being worked on and they have a
proposal in the works for a blast for pi
detector which would certainly enable
them to really use the capabilities of
the cell soil ring and it's polarized
internal targets so that is the few
brief highlights on our medium energy
program now let's go to hundreds of
physics and I call this life away from
home see how are we going do that going
back to the tree here we find as many
many things you'll find green shoots
Brown shoots things sprouting things
leaving the work in the laboratory
started in building 24 the 300 MeV
electron cyclotron then to CEA and then
to Brookhaven to the AG s to the cosmic
Ron earlier then Desi Homburg discern
and in terms of our current program we
take a look at we're not running an
experiment and with collaborators at the
CDF facility Jerry Friedman is the
spokesperson Paris ficus and others we
are winding down work at s LD detector
at the Stanford Linear Collider and I'll
mention that in a moment we have a
vigorous program at King at l3 at the
lepor accelerator facility
we are engaged in some generic R&D for
new detectors through Minchin and Ulrich
Becker and we haven't were part of the
gem collaboration looking forward to
doing work at the SSC so in this area
certainly much is going on let us take a
look at the early years I remind our
visitors once again at what we're taking
a look at now is certainly the
elementary particles of the nucleus
possibly sub elementary particles and
this all of this started here in the
laboratory in building 24 but before
doing I like to with apologies that
Henry Kendall our physicist Mountaineer
by not that my opinion some of these
experiments are like climbing a mountain
you the logistics has to be there
planning and schedules are very very
important the group has to be highly
motivated and occasionally even though
you have good backup and excellent
techniques for reasons unknown province
you may not reach the top here we have
the MIT signature on 300 MeV electron
signature on this is a picture of
sergeant James and some really
experiments distinct simple here's what
we call the Snow Maiden
a tube filled full of pressurized
hydrogen to study the photo production
of Nissan's a little bit more
complicated experiment in this case to
study that the production of u plus mu
minus pairs none Racine and then onto CA
in the early in 1960s this was a joint
Harvard MIT affair ring about 240 feet
in diameter 60 GeV electrons sandwiched
in between the Divinity School and the
Harvard Physics Department much
interesting work went on there now we
have this is Moby Dick a single arm
spectrometer that Louie husband and
collaborators built for the photo
production of new and unusual particles
at CEA
here we have a device called a bubble
chamber and dick Yamamoto Larry Rosen
sonoran plus a number of these are built
in the laboratory this was a heavy
liquid chamber then on the well just
getting ahead of my tail a bit here we
have what a particle coming into such a
chamber looks like see these tracks now
one of the problems have developed we
also spirited work in spark chambers is
how do you analyze all this data a
continually a continual problem in high
energy physics and Erwin Etta's group
developed a pepper device and Martin
developed spas for the analyzing of data
from spark chambers then on the morning
of July 5th 1965 I got a call from Lewis
Warren saying see a is on fire
and when I got to see a here's what I
saw certainly great devastation and
looking at the experimental area one saw
this as you imagine there was a
investigation by the AEC they determined
that with high probability what caused
the fire was the rupture of abou the
beryllium window in the four and a 500
liter hydrogen bubble chamber following
that I must say that the laboratory
joined together like it probably never
has and probably never will again one
young technician died as a result there
were seven injured and we all work
together at the hospital to try to do
what we could one young man spent a year
in the hospital came back to MIT got his
BS got his PhD and and just a certainly
a figure of a supreme courage CEA was
rebuilt the bubble chambers were rebuilt
out in Billerica at IBM railroad siding
and one had to certainly between pigeons
dropping and what-have-you one was able
to get it all together
he went to Argonne there was a budget
crotch crunch and it was never run since
hell let me take a look at sort of
moving out moving from on campus to off
campus instrumentation simple to complex
collaborators
you complex pioneering work at slack
Jerry Friedman Henry Kendall and dick
Taylor where they discovered keeping a
lasting work with the proton and neutron
may have a substructure called quarks
and for this apologies to Jerry we have
him receiving the Nobel Prize about two
and a half decades later along with
Henry and dick and a pioneering
experiment at Brookhaven using a double
arm spectrometer at the EGS facility
with high resolution the J particle was
discovered can we say Bert Richter
roughly the same time this resulted in a
Nobel Prize the tank and then a day I
show this because the historical
interest that a celebration held in the
Corcoran because here you have some of
the directors of L&S Jerry Friedman
Martin Deutsch here you have Arthur
Kerman Vicky Herman and I think Vicky
giving Stan a little bit of advice then
on to Fermilab larger experiments and
getting more complex this was one to the
Contra spark chamber group worked on or
neutrinos studies let me just show you
this picture that shows you one of the
problems you have getting data out
look at these thousands and thousands of
cables a very very tough logistic copper
and along the way in that experiment the
world's largest proportional chamber
series of chambers was developed due to
the ingenuity of this fellow right here
Tommy Lyons and then on to mark J at
desi some of Sam Kings worked there
resulted in the finding of the Jets and
the gluon and the glue on the carrier
the strong force between the quarks was
discovered there and onto the ISR at
CERN
this is UA one who revel in this group
were working with Ruby and others and
through the analysis of pictures such as
you see right here the W and the zebra
discovered and then to Gran Sasso the
world's largest underground laboratory
in Italy or urban plus Martin
and others are engaged in the
experiments taking a look at some of the
highest energy cosmic rays to see if new
phenomena can be discovered looking at
solar neutrinos and here is a Herman on
one of his frequent visits to Gran Sasso
and then moving on to some of the large
detectors and large accelerators and
here we have colliding beams coming
together matter changing into energy
back into matter were known and new
particles hopefully looked at we were
heavily involved at the SLD detector at
SLAC the counter-strike jammer group had
had a major commitment in the warm iron
developing the warming calorimeter here
you get some idea the size of these
giants and the complexity of the of the
infrastructure is that right yeah and
even an a an event showing these series
of jets we then are doing work at the
CDF detector at Fermilab and at the L 3
experiment in Geneva a worldwide effort
the laboratory has spent a lot of time
and effort on this and the management
side of things
goe has put in for the first phase
something like 42 million dollars
through LNS and with the second phase
something like an additional 10 to 12 it
was the first collaboration between
Europe the u.s. our US and China meeting
these physicists working with them a
certainly a great pleasure the machine
was immense about 16 miles around here
we have the Geneva Airport and many of
us I figured I've landed and taken off
here about some 80 times and round-trips
covering some 500,000 miles but that's
not unique you'll find all of our energy
physicists do that today they're away
from home they're landing out in the
west coast at Brookhaven Geneva at Desi
Hamburg and it's just a way of life the
times are very tough way of life
here you have the ll3 detector here's a
man you can see the huge size of this
detector and to give you a better
feeling here our magnet coils about four
stories high and looking down here you
have the support - and looking into the
magnet and here are the see if I get
this right the magnet doors and
occasionally you find yourself popping
first of all I should mention that that
experiment is running here is a possible
Higgs candidate the Higgs being risk
presumably responsible for massive some
or all of the elementary particles you'd
like to get more events of this kind so
the Higgs search is on but occasionally
you find yourself and rather interesting
books the l3 magnet found its way into
the Guinness Book of Records more steel
than the Eiffel tire tower something
like 8,000 tons one problem you had with
a huge collaboration like that is names
on paper so here we are the names on the
first couple of papers and this led to
the cartoon look at this article on zero
decay a mustard is one of the co-authors
then on to the SSC the superconductor
supercollider some 53 miles around being
built you walk say heck heck see Texas
how are we involved certainly at this
machine you're now looking at hopefully
with its energies and the 20 TeV range
possibly the makeup of the quarks
themselves new phenomena you're looking
at certainly now huge detectors where
you don't put a person down here but now
you have to put a dumptruck to indicate
something about the size of these
detectors well several things if I can
see it in a very trite way you win some
and you lose some the laboratory through
the Contra spark chamber group had an
impact proposal ting through L star had
had a proposal I should say a letter of
intent
both are rejected but physicists being
physicists we now find our Condor spark
chamber coop as part of the gem
collaboration gamma rays electrons muons
and and here is a schematic of that huge
device here is a person right here and
ting in this group are engaged certainly
yet were concern and looking forward to
doing work with the LHC if indeed that
new machine the large electron Hadron
Collider is approved now let me take one
last look at the tree and I can't forget
certainly theoretical physics here we
have just green shoots scintillating
stellar I would describe that work going
right back to the early days there was a
center formed Herman Feshbach Arthur
Kerman John negly and others but supreme
leadership indeed according to Zacharias
the nuclear and particle physicists
exterior vinter acted not only among
themselves but certainly with the rest
of the laboratory you can see some of
the directors and some of the things
that they have done but I think in each
physicist there's probably a little bit
of the poet and artist so he asked John
negly John can you do a little bit about
embellishing that branch and again with
the help of the
computer here is what John came forward
with and it just attempts to illustrate
some of the many many things that have
taken part at the center doorway States
collect emotion strings nuclear
structure and forces going back to the
early days the bag model EMI approves of
nucleon hadrons anomalies and certainly
work on the inflationary universe baby
universes and what-have-you and then of
course putting it all together is this
early photograph of Vickie which
certainly is where this group started it
was end with Herman's being strongly
involved now in just some last comments
where are we today
structured the laboratory as basically
this and not too unchanged and what we
saw 46 years ago its budget has climbed
to about a level of around 30 million
dollars a year with that of course the
paperwork has gone up here's one
proposal to the do-e about 70 pounds
that we issue every spring about this
time we take a look at the campus and we
ask where are the accelerators gone
we're now concentrating our efforts in
building 24 building 26 and one of the
things in talking with people about the
laboratory this matter fluidity and
talking with Roy Rosen said about some
of his work one it came really forward
that indeed one of the strengths of the
laboratories that physicists move around
groups chains coalesce reorganize that
has been one of our great strengths over
the years then at times we all work
under pressure and I'd like to spay say
just pay my compliments to those in our
central facilities and our compatriots
at Bates bill Loeb our Sheila Dodson
Gary Nixon and others over the years who
have certainly worked under great
pressure I show this to of these
gentlemen are no longer with us this was
taken at the time of Kings celebration
history turns and trivial chances
offices and momentous tides
sometimes the dragon wins and then from
Vicki's book if one takes a look at his
paperback what it's all about is
certainly the acquisition of knowledge
and the wonder I think that goes with it
and I'd like to conclude if he won't
mind reading a poem from his recent book
but I think some of puts us all into
perspective joyfully a patient lover
mankind's eager spirit strove to unravel
and discover her creative nature wove it
revealed that one eternal essence / made
it all in the grains of Sheldon kernel
at the heart of great and small always
changing and yet holding things together
for an ear shaping endlessly unfolding
to behold it we are here ok thank
[Applause]